- [Presenter] This program is presented
by University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
(upbeat music)
- Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Mary Comerio, professor
of the Graduate School
in Architecture and chair
of the Hitchcock Professorship Committee.
We are pleased, along
with the Graduate Council,
to present Carol Greider,
this year's speaker
in the Charles M. and Martha
Hitchcock lecture series.
As a condition of this request,
we are obligated and happy to tell you
how the endowment came to UC Berkeley.
It is a story that
exemplifies, in many ways,
the campus linked to the
history of California
and to the Bay Area.
Dr. Charles Hitchcock, a
physician for the army,
came to San Francisco
during the gold rush,
where he opened a
thriving private practice.
In 1885, Charles established
a professorship here at Berkeley
as an expression of his
long-held interest in education.
His daughter, Lily Hitchcock Coit,
still treasured in San Francisco
for her colorful personality
as well as her generosity,
greatly expanded her
father's original gift,
to establish a professorship
at UC Berkeley,
making it possible for us to
present a series of lectures.
The Hitchcock fund has become one
of the most cherished endowments
of the University of California,
recognizing the highest distinction
of scholarly thought and achievement.
Thank you, Lily and Charles.
And now, a few words about Carol Greider.
Carol Greider is internationally renowned
for her important contributions
to the field of molecular biology.
She was awarded the 2009 Nobel Prize
for physiology of medicine,
along with Elizabeth
Blackburn and Jack Szostak,
for their discovery that genetic sequences
known as telomeres are protected
from progressive shortening
by the enzyme telomerase.
Greider discovered telomerase in 1984,
while working with Elizabeth Bradford
at the University of California Berkeley.
Telomeres are essential
to chromosome maintenance and stability.
In the absence of telomerase,
telomeres shorten
progressively as cells divide,
eventually leading to cell death
or cellular senescence.
Greider's understanding,
Greider's breakthrough discovery
of telomerase enzyme that allowed
a mechanistic understanding
of cellular reproduction,
opening new avenues of
research into cancer
and age-related diseases.
Greider received her BA in biology
from the University of California,
Santa Barbara, in 1983, her
PhD in molecular biology
at the University of
California, Berkeley, in 1987.
She was a Cold Spring Harbor fellow
and later held a faculty position
at the Cold Spring Harbor Laboratory
in Long Island, New York.
In 1997, she joined the faculty
of the Department of
Molecular Biology and Genetics
at Johns Hopkins University
where she is currently the
Daniel Nathans professor
and director of molecular
biology and genetics,
as well as professor of oncology
in the John Hopkins
University School of Medicine.
Greider also directs her
own research laboratory
at the University which conducts research
into telomere function and structure.
In recognition of her
groundbreaking research,
Greider has been named a fellow
by the American Academy of Microbiology,
the American Association for
the Advancement of Science,
the American Academy of Arts and Sciences,
and as a member of the
National Academy of Sciences
and the Institute of Medicine.
In addition to her Nobel Prize
for physiology of medicine,
she has received a number of other awards
in the last 10 years,
including the Pearl
Meister Greengard Prize,
the Paul Ehrlich, Ludwig
Darmstaedter Prize,
the Kathryn Burke and Judd Award,
the Richard Lounsbery Award,
the Dickson Prize in Medicine,
the Wiley Prize in Biomedical Sciences
and the Louisa Gross Horowitz Prize.
An amazing list.
Greider has also published
over 100 articles and book chapters.
Please join me in welcoming
Carol Greider back to Berkeley.
(audience applauding)
- Well, it's really a pleasure to be here.
I've been looking forward
to this lecture series
for a number of months now.
It's always a pleasure to
come back here to Berkeley
and to be here in the I-House.
Not only did I get my PhD here at Berkeley
but both my mother and my father
received their PhDs here at Berkeley
so it really is like a homecoming.
So thank you very much
for this invitation.
So what I would like to do today,
is to give you a sense of the background
of why we thought telomeres and telomerase
were interesting and
take you on a little bit
of a journey from the initial discovery
of the function of telomeres,
through how, now, we understand
they play a role in age-related disease
So the theme of this
lecture is going to be
that curiosity-driven
research can establish
fundamental knowledge that
fuels practical applications.
So we'll start at the beginning
or perhaps we'll start at the end
because telomeres are at both
the beginning and the ends of chromosomes.
So if you have, within a cell,
the nucleus and in the nucleus
are all of the chromosomes
and this is a blow-up of
one of those chromosomes
and so most of what is studied
in the field of molecular biology
occurs along the length
of the chromosomes,
where all of the genes and
the control elements lie
but we'll be focusing today on this region
at the end which is called the telomere.
Telomeres provide two really important
functions for the cell.
First of all, they have to
protect the chromosome ends.
They protect the chromosome ends
from anything that would chew away,
a nucleus that may chew
a way from the end.
They protect the ends from
recombination with other ends
and they protect the ends
from fusion with other ends.
So this is a really essential
function for chromosome maintenance.
The other thing that telomeres have to do,
is to allow the maintenance
of chromosome length
and we'll be going through
why that is very important
throughout most of the rest of the talk.
So telomeres were first
functionally defined
by H.J. Muller and by Barbara McClintock
back in the late 30s and early 40s.
So, Muller, working in Drosophila,
showed that telomeres were essential
to protect chromosome ends and McClintock
was working in the plant, maize or corn
and also came to the same conclusion,
that the telomeres were necessary
for protecting the chromosome ends.
So this was a very early discovery
and it wasn't possible
to really understand,
in molecular detail, what a telomere was
or how carried out its function
until it was characterized
at the very molecular level.
And so that occurred in the 1970s
with this organism here,
Tetrahymena thermophila.
So Tetrahymena is a single-celled,
ciliated protozoum.
If you went to the creek,
you'd be able to take some pond water
and see ciliates swimming around.
And the Tetrahymena is very unique
because a single cell
contains 40,000 chromosomes.
So this was the organism of choice
to try and identify what
is the molecular basis
for the function of these telomeres.
And so in 1978, Elizabeth Blackburn,
working together with Joe Gall,
were able to define the molecular
sequence, the DNA sequence
that's at the very end of the chromosome.
And what they found is that
there was a very simple,
repeated DNA sequence.
So the DNA has normally four
different building blocks,
T, G, C, and A.
In this case, it was simple repeats
of two Ts followed by four Gs
and then hundreds of those repeats,
on the ends of the chromosomes.
So this was a very
important initial finding
because it then allowed
additional experiments
to be carried out to understand
the function of telomeres.
So here's Joe gall and Liz Blackburn.
I'm going to introduce
a number of the people
along the way because one of the themes
in science is, of course,
it's not just one person
making a discovery but many people
building on what others have done.
So I'll try and give you a flavor
of some of the people that
have done the experiments
that I'm talking about, as I go along.
So the first identification
of the DNA sequences
of telomeres, as I said,
was in this ciliated
protozoan tetrahymena.
And the telomere sequence
was identified as T2, G4,
repeats of this sequence.
And then subsequent work by a number
of other laboratories was able to show
that very similar, tandemly repeated,
simple GT-rich sequences were present
in a variety of other organisms.
So for instance, in fungi,
there's a model organism,
Saccharomyces cerevisiae.
And here, the sequence was T,
followed by either one,
two, or three G residues.
And then I'll also be talking
about the human telomeric sequence.
And in all vertebrates, including humans,
the sequence is TTAGGG,
repeated many times.
So this theme, it turns out,
repeats itself throughout
various organisms
and this is one thing that's very nice
about working on something
that is very fundamental
to biology and that is
that the same themes
occur throughout many different organisms.
So the telomeric DNA contains
these tandem repeats of simple sequences.
And of course, most of the DNA
in a cell is double-stranded,
so you have both the TG-rich sequence,
as well as a CA-rich sequence.
Although there is a region at the very end
of the chromosome in which
it's single-stranded.
But in order to carry out
this function of telomeres,
you require not just
the DNA but of course,
there have to be proteins
that bind to that DNA,
that actually carry out the function
of the protecting the chromosome.
and in mammalian cells,
this is a complex of proteins
called the Sheltering Complex,
which protect the chromosome ends
and so there are proteins that bind
along the length of the
double strand of the DNA,
proteins that to those proteins,
and the proteins that also protect
this single strand region.
And it's together, this complex
of the proteins in the DNA, that carry out
the telomere function that
we'll be discussing today.
So it turns out that it
was first hypothesized
by Jim Watson and by others,
that if you look at the mechanism
by which chromosomes are copied,
every time a cell has to divide,
that it was predicted that the chromosomes
should shorten from their ends
every time the cell divides.
And this is because of
the molecular mechanism
that replicates the entire
length of the chromosome.
So what one would predict
is that every time
a cell divides, the
telomeres should shorten
from their ends.
And so you would have a loss
of these telomeric repeats.
However, it turns out that
the way most organisms
that have these linear chromosomes
overcome this problem in replication
is through this enzyme telomerase
and that's what we were able
to show from Tetrahymena.
So you may have some
telomere shortening here
but then the telomerase
will add these repeats
back on to the ends of chromosomes
so that chromosomes
aren't a unique length,
rather there's an equilibrium.
There's always some shortening
and then some lengthening
and some shortening and some lengthening
and that way, the average length
of the average telomere
is maintained over time.
So this is a rather baroque mechanism
that doesn't really avoid
the shortening problem
but rather, overcomes it.
So we've been interested
in this telomerase enzyme
for a number of years.
And of course, we don't
usually look at it,
as this kind of a little cartoon,
we're interested a little bit more
in the details of the mechanism.
But I won't really have a chance
to get into many of
those details here today
but I'll just show you
some of the components
that go into this so telomerase,
so that I can tell you a little bit
about how we study its role.
So the telomerase is a
really remarkable enzyme.
It actually contains protein components
as well as an essential RNA component.
So this is unusual for an enzyme.
So this stick figure here
is meant to represent
the RNA component of telomerase.
And the RNA component of telomerase
actually has a region which can base pair
with the telomere to be able to add
these telomeric repeats onto
the ends of the chromosome.
And I'm introducing
this, not so much today,
to tell you about how
telomerase does this,
which is really a fascinating question,
but rather to introduce
you to the components
of telomerase that I'll be
discussing throughout the talk.
So this protein here that carries out
a telomerase function, we call a TERT,
for telomerase reverse transcriptase.
And so this carries out the catalytic
function of telomerase.
And this RNA component,
we imaginatively call telomerase RNA,
abbreviated, TR.
So you'll be hearing
about these components
throughout the rest of the talk.
So having discovered that the way
that telomeres are maintained,
rather than having them shorten every time
the cells divide, rather to be maintained
by telomerase, we were
very curious to know
what would happen if you
don't have telomeres?
What would be the consequence
of not being able to
elongate the telomeres?
And so that led us, and
a number of other labs,
to two really fundamental
consequences of telomerase.
So the question is why
does telomerase matter?
And it turns out that it's required
for all cells that have
to divide many times.
So I'll be telling you
a little bit of a story
where telomerase is required
for the growth of cancer cells.
So if you imagine that
you have a particular
set of cells here.
One of those cells undergoes
some kind of a genetic change,
which allows it to divide more times
than it normally should.
So that's this red cell here.
And that red cell then will go and divide
many more times relative to
the other cells around it.
And it turns out, in order for that cell
to continue dividing and form that tumor,
it has to solve this telomere problem,
that is the problem with
the telomere shortening
every time the cells divide.
So these cancer cells need have telomerase
in order to maintain their telomeres
to go on and continue dividing.
So I'll tell you a little bit about that.
Telomerase is also essential
for a number of other cells in our body
which have to also divide many times
and these would be stem cells
or tissue specific stem cells,
where you have a cell that makes
a copy of itself but then also has to make
what are called pluripotent stem cells,
these are our cells that will go on
and make the final tissue.
So this, again, are
cells that have to divide
many times in order to replenish
the other cells in the body.
So these are the two areas
that the telomerase clearly
plays an important role.
And we'll be talking,
toward the end of the talk,
about how this role here
plays a role in age-related
degenerative disease.
So we were very curious
about the role of telomerase
and what might happen if
you didn't have telomerase,
so we set out to generate a mouse
which doesn't have this activity.
So instead of being able
to maintain the telomeres
by adding repeats onto the end,
we generated a knockout so
it had no telomerase at all.
And then we wanted to study what happens
to that mouse when the
telomeres get to be short.
So the way that we generated this mouse
that doesn't have telomerase,
was we had identified, as I told you,
the telomerase RNA, that's
abbreviated here, TR.
The M stands for the mouse,
so it's the mouse version
of the telomerase RNA.
And we generated mice
because mice are diploid.
Of course, they have two
copies of chromosomes.
One from their mom and one from their dad.
So we generated these mice
which are heterozygous,
in which, they have one normal copy
of the telomerase RNA
and then the other copy
is just missing the telomerase RNA.
So it's a minus.
So it has one copy instead of two copies.
When you then take two such mice
and you breed them together,
as Mendel told us from genetics,
what you would get by breeding
these two mice together,
is you get mice that have two copies
of the telomerase RNA, mice
that are heterozygotes,
or have, like their parents,
one normal copy and one missing copy
or you get the mice
that are completely null
for telomerase and have
no enzyme whatsoever.
So we generated these mice and remarkably,
the mice were perfectly fine.
There was nothing wrong with them at all
and so we were curious what might happen
over time with these mice.
So we designated these mice as the G1,
that is the first generation
that lack telomerase.
So these G1 mice were
then bred to each other
and of course, you'd breed the G1 mice,
so these are null.
You get the G2 knockout mice.
You breed those mice together, you get G3.
Et cetera, G4, G5, and G6.
And I'll be showing you
that in these G6 animals,
we can't get a later generation
because one of the things that happens,
is these mice become infertile.
There are a number of other consequences
of the loss of telomerase
but we don't get future generations.
So as these mice are breeding,
what we found is that the telomeres,
with each generation of mouse,
were getting shorter and shorter.
So the cartoon version
of this is shown here.
We breed the G1 mice and we get the G2.
We take these two G2
mice and now the G3 mice
have shorter telomeres
than their parents did.
And then you breed the
G3 mice to each other
and the G4 mice have
even shorter telomeres.
So with progressive generations,
there was progressive telomere shortening
and the way that we actually look at this
in the laboratory is a
very nice visual assay
that was developed by Peter Lansdorp.
And what this is, is a way to look
at all of the chromosomes in the mice.
So these are metaphase spreads.
So you take the the cells
when they're about to divide
and you can visualize the chromosomes
which are shown here in blue,
with a stain that's staining the DNA
and then the telomeres are visualized
with a fluorescent probe that recognizes
the telomere and the
intensity of this spot,
that is how many probes
are hybridizing there,
is proportional to how
long the telomere is.
So the brighter the spot,
that means you have a longer telomere.
And this is a very nice assay
because you can actually
see what's happening
to the chromosomes.
So this is how we were able
to look at telomere length.
And what we found when
you breed these mice down
in this nice line here is if you look
at the intensity of each one
of those red dots from before
versus the number of dots
that have that intensity,
you have this nice distribution
and this distribution is the normal way
that telomeres are maintained
and they're maintained
about this equilibrium
because there's some
shortening and lengthening
and shortening and lengthening.
However, with each generation,
now, this is the G2, the G4, and the G6,
you can see that there's
progressively shorter
and shorter telomeres with each generation
that these mice are bred.
One of the nice things
about this visual assay,
where you're actually
looking at the chromosomes,
is that we could show that not only
are we losing telomeric
sequence with each generation,
but we're actually losing
telomeric function.
And I'll be telling you, in just a minute,
that we see effects
that is phenotypes in
these later generation mice
that we don't see in the
the first generation mice,
indicating that the short telomeres
are what's causing effects in these mice.
So when we actually look
at the different generations of mice,
here is the wild-type mouse chromosomes
that I showed you, with these red dots
on the ends of the chromosomes.
And you can see that
these mouse chromosomes
look like these little boomerangs,
they look like little Vs
because the centromere is all the way
along one end of the chromosome.
So they're attached here and then the two
long arms are going off here.
So you see this nice spread
of mouse chromosomes.
In the second generation,
you also see that,
and also the fourth and in the sixth.
But what was remarkable
is that in these very later generations,
what you see here is what
looks like two chromosomes
that have now fused through their ends.
Instead of being little boomerangs,
they're two that are
attached to each other
and what that indicates is that not only
have we lost telomere sequence,
but we've lost telomere function.
Because I told you that what telomeres do
is to protect the chromosome ends
and it protects them from
these kinds of recombination.
So we can actually see
this loss of telomere function visually.
So the mice,
once they get to be in the
fifth and sixth generation,
it turns out, have a number
of problems with them.
So I mentioned, in the testes,
that these mice become infertile.
So there's actually a cell
death of the germ cells.
In the intestine, the
normal intestinal cells
which allow cell turnover
isn't occurring properly,
so you have this atrophy.
In the blood, there's bone marrow failure.
So the blood is one cell type
where you have to have
cells continually renewing
because blood cells are dying every day.
In the skin, there's
decreased wound healing
and there was premature graying
of these late generation mice.
And it was remarkable that
all of these phenotypes
seen in these mice were seen
in the fifth and sixth generation mice.
Okay, they were seen when
the telomeres were short
but not in the first generation mice
when telomerase was absent.
So what that tells us is
that it takes some time
for the telomeres to get short
and it must be the short telomeres
that are causing these effects, okay?
So it's not the absence
of the telomerase enzyme
because if it were the
absence of telomerase,
you would see that in the
very first generation.
The fact that we have to
wait for six generations
means it must be the short telomeres
that are causing these effects.
So I'm going to tell you now
about work from a student
who was able to show
that it was actually
the shortest telomeres
that that caused this effect.
And this was Mike Hemann.
And Mike did a series of experiments,
crossing mice with long telomeres
and mice with short telomeres
and what he was able to to show
is that it's actually
the shortest telomere
that leads to either
cell death or senescence.
So just like the different
generations of mice,
the mice with the long
telomeres, there's no effect.
As those cells are dividing now,
the telomeres become short
and the shortest telomere
in the cell is actually recognized
and it tells the cell that
there is damage going on
and what happens is the
cells either undergo
cell death or cellular senescence.
So cell death, you actually
get the absence of the cells
and cellular senescence is a phenomenon
where the cells just stop dividing
and they won't divide any further
but they're still staying around.
So it's clearly the short telomeres
that are causing this effect.
So we were interested,
then, in the consequence
of this short telomeres
causing cell death.
And so I'll tell you one short story
where we were interested
in how this may play
a role in cancer.
So we were interested in a
particular kind of cancer
and that's a cancer that
causes B-cell lymphoma.
So this is a leukemia type cancer.
And model mouse had been developed
and we called that mouse Emu-myc
because this expresses
a particular oncogene
and this mouse had been characterized
and it's very tumor prone
and will develop this B-cell lymphoma.
So what we were able to do, then,
is to cross this with
the telomerase-null mouse
and ask what happens when
telomerase is not there.
Can that tumor go on and develop?
And so of course, we have to be able
to understand what happens when you first
get rid of telomerase.
So we look at the the first generation,
the Emu-myc mice at are G1
and then of course, have to
breed and get the G2 mice,
the G3 mice, et cetera,
all the way up through the G6 mice
to understand the role
of the short telomeres
in this development of the tumor.
So what we find is that there's a change
in the survival of the
mice due to these tumors.
And so I'll just walk you
through this graph here.
This shows the percent
of mice that are alive
at the beginning of the experiment
versus the number of days.
And so what's shown in the black line here
is this mouse which has been made prone
to these B-cell lymphomas.
And so at the start, 100%
of the mice are alive
but if you follow this black line,
you can see that as time progresses,
at 100 days, about half
of these mice have died
and they've all died of
this B-cell lymphoma.
So they get this tumor
at a very high rate.
If we now look at the mice
which were absent for telomeres,
so they now don't have telomeres,
but they're the very first
generation that lacked telomeres.
What you find is a very
similar curve here in blue.
So all of these mice are
dying of B-cell lymphoma
and they're all have
succumbed to this lymphoma
by about 200 days.
However, in contrast,
when we breed that out
to the sixth generation,
where now the telomeres are
very short in these mice,
what we find is that
although there are some mice
that die early on, most
of the mice now survive
and what you can see in these mice
is that lymphoma started to grow
but then it stopped growing
and it stopped growing
because the telomeres were very short.
And as I told you, the short telomeres
then cause either cell death
or cellular senescence,
so they couldn't go on
and form that tumor cell.
And so this is one indication
that the the short telomeres will limit
the growth of cells and in this setting,
it's limiting the growth
of these cancer cells.
So the short telomeres will
block the tumor growth.
They don't block the early
stages that cause the cancer
but what they do is they block
the growth of the cancer cells.
So the telomerase itself
isn't playing a role
in the initiation of the cancer.
However, when you have short telomeres,
after those cells start
to grow for a while,
you now block at this stage and the cells
can no longer go on and
form the full-blown tumor.
So this was the work of David Feldser
who was another graduate student
in the laboratory who was breeding
these telomeres-null mice
to the B-cell lymphoma mice.
So the other aspect I would like to focus
on now for the rest of the talk
is the role of telomerase
in tissue renewal.
So we were very interested
in some of the early
effects that we saw in our 6th generation
telomerase knockout mice.
And we wanted to understand a little bit
more clearly what
happens in normal tissues
when you don't have telomerase
and the telomeres become short.
So a number of years earlier,
we had been involved in a collaboration
with Cal Harley where we had shown
and others have also
shown that if you take
normal human cells and
you put those into culture
and you grow them for a
number of cell divisions,
it turns out what happens
is that the telomeres
shorten progressively
as the cells are dividing.
So this is this end replication problem
that I told you about.
And so what is shown
here is a representation
of the distribution of telomere
lengths in human cells.
Again, there's this heterogeneity
of the telomere lengths.
And as these cells are dividing,
the length of this
telomere actually decreases
as the cells are dividing in culture.
So this was a first
indication that telomerase
may play a role, that short telomeres
may play a role in the inability
of human cells to continue to divide.
And then a similar
phenomenon is actually seen
in people, not in cells and culture,
but rather with people of different age.
So if you look at the mean telomere length
and the way that we get
that mean telomere length,
this is a representation
of the telomere length
and so you can determine
how long a telomere is here,
versus how long the mean telomere is here
and if you simply plot
this on this graph here
and look at mean telomere length
versus the age of the person
from which you took those blood cells,
so this is now in normal
human white blood cells,
what you find is that there
is progressive shortening
of the telomeres with increasing
numbers of cell division.
Now, at first what we thought
that this might represent
is the fact that these white blood cells
might not have telomerase activity
and therefore the telomeres
are shortening progressively.
Although what I'm going to show you
is that they do have
some telomerase activity
but the number of times white blood cells
have to divide outstrips the ability
of the telomerase to be able to keep up
and elongate the telomeres.
So over this long course
of cell divisions,
what you see is this progressive
telomere shortening in the bulk
of the white blood cells
in all normal individuals.
So the point that I'm going to make
is that telomerase is limiting in cells.
There's really just
enough telomerase activity
in order to keep up with telomeres
on the chromosomes that are where
the telomeres are the shortest.
So this story comes from a
number of different angles
but the first hint that
the short telomeres
might play a role in human disease
came actually, again, from understanding
molecular components
just like understanding
the molecular component of
the telomere DNA sequence
allowed us to understand what happens
with telomere shortening.
In this case, it's
understanding the structure
of the RNA component.
So the telomerase RNA
has this structure here
and it was first identified
with Cathy Collin's lab,
here at Berkeley and also in my lab,
that there's this
particular structure here
which binds to a set of proteins,
in addition to this TERT protein
which is necessary for
telomerase activity.
There's a set of proteins
that binds to this structure
and one of those proteins
involves this protein
here called dyskerin.
And this dyskerin protein was known
to be involved in human genetic disease.
And so that then led to just
the next year after this,
a publication by a group
of human geneticists
who were very interested in this disease,
dyskeratosis congenita.
And I'll tell you just in a second
what dyskeratosis congenita is,
but what was happening
here is that this group
was very interested in this
inherited human disease.
And so they were mapping, in families,
this disease, not knowing what caused it.
And by doing this genetic mapping,
they were then able to
identify that in this case,
the cause was the RNA
component of telomerase.
So the title of the paper
that was published in 2001,
the RNA component of telomerase
is mutated in autosomal
dominant dyskeratosis congenita.
So this really galvanized people
to understand how it is that telomerase
can play a role in this
inherited genetic disease.
So the clinical manifestations
of dyskeratosis congenita.
It gets its name because
of skin and nail problems.
Fingernails and toenails.
That's why the term is dyskeratosis,
because of the keratosis
in the fingernails and the skin.
So that's how the physicians
would see their patient,
that was the most common
visual manifestation of this disease.
Although it was known that
the mortality of the disease
was due to bone marrow failure.
Okay, so the inability of the bone marrow
to continue making all
of normal blood cells
that we require every single day.
So this is an example of this requirement
for stem cells to differentiate
into all of the different
blood cell types.
So that was the initial characterization
of the human disease and the question was,
how is it that the telomerase
can play a role in this human disease?
So we got involved with
this at Johns Hopkins
because a patient came in
to the hematology clinic
at Johns Hopkins and as I was mentioning,
we don't do science in a vacuum.
We talked to our colleagues
and I was talking
with a variety of the people
in the clinical departments
to understand how to study
the blood cell effects
and this patient came in,
and this is the family of this patient.
But this patient came into the clinic
and was diagnosed as having this disease,
dyskeratosis congenita.
And so at the time, Mary Armanios
decided to understand
more about this family
because what was known was
that this keratosis congenita
was often mutations in this
RNA component of telomerase.
So she brought these individuals
within this family into the clinic
and was able to identify
that there weren't mutations
in the RNA component of
telomerase but there are mutations
in the protein component of telomerase.
So again, this is a
telomerase-mediated disease.
And I show you this family,
this individual that came into the clinic
and his father and his grandmother
and those individuals here shown in black
had these changes, these mutations,
in the telomerase, in the family.
And so this inheritance of this disease
was shown to be autosomal dominant
and I'll tell you a little
bit about what we know
about that autosomal dominant inheritance.
One of the remarkable
things about this family
was that the the disease showed something
that we call genetic anticipation.
And that's a fancy way of saying
that with each generation
that has the disease,
there's an earlier onset of the disease
and more severity of the disease, okay?
And this may remind you of
our telomerase knockout mouse.
In the telomerase knockout mouse,
we didn't see anything in
the first few generations
but then we saw effects
in the later generations.
And so the same thing
seemed to be occurring
in this human family with
this inherited disease.
The other thing that was
really quite remarkable
is that those people that
were affected with the disease
and had this bone marrow failure
actually were heterozygous.
That is, they contained one normal copy
and one mutant copy of
the telomerase gene.
And that was quite remarkable to us
because in a lot of
human genetic diseases,
you have to have two mutant copies
in order to actually have an effect.
So this really got us thinking
about how could it be that
you could be heterozygous,
that is, have one normal
copy and one mutant copy.
And so as geneticist,
what we thought about,
was two molecular mechanisms
that might underlie
this inheritance pattern
in these families.
And one of those is what's
called dominant negative
and the other is haploinsufficiency.
So what that basically means
is that if you have one mutant
copy and one normal copy
it could be that the
mutant copy actually binds
to the normal copy and
takes it out of function.
So that's a dominant mechanism.
The mutant is dominant
over the normal copy.
An alternative would be that
you have one mutant copy
and one normal copy and
it's just not enough
to have one normal copy of the telomerase.
And so we realized that
we were in the position
where we could test this
genetically, directly in our mice.
So that's what we set out to do,
was to determine whether
there's a dominant effect
or whether it's haploinsufficiency.
And what I'll tell you, is our evidence
that it's actually haploinsufficiency.
It's just not enough to have only one copy
of the functional telomerase.
So what's shown here is a representation
of the the telomeres again.
This is a southern blot.
But now we're looking at mice,
so these are the the mice
that we had initially been characterizing.
And you can see that there's this very,
very long, heterogeneous size
to the telomeres in this
particular strain of mice.
However, we looked at a variety
of other strains of mice and
this is one that's shown here
and you can see that the long telomeres
that are here in this initial strain,
now are represented by a
much less heterogeneous
and shorter telomere
length in this other strain
of mice that we call castaneous,
for Cast/Ei.
And so we thought that
we would be able to see
what's actually happening to telomeres
much more easily on this
new genetic background.
And I'll just represent that here.
So if you imagine that you
have this telomere length
with the signal intensity
of those red spots,
the original mouse that we were using
had very long heterozygous telomeres.
However, this new mouse has much shorter,
much more homogeneous telomeres.
And so what we imagined might happen,
would be, after you have
telomere shortening,
if there's a threshold
below which the telomeres
have to go before you have some sort
of functional consequence,
when you have telomere
shortening in these settings,
a much higher proportion of the cells
would fall below this threshold
when you have this much more
homogeneous telomere length.
And so that's what we had set out to do,
was to generate mice that now
have a much more homogeneous
set of telomeres.
And these experiments
actually were initiated
by Mike Hemann, who I showed you earlier,
and then continued by Ling-Yang Hao,
who then really had some
remarkable discoveries.
So what Ling-Yang set out to do,
was to take these mice now,
where we can see phenotypes more easily
and to ask, what happens if these mice
are always have one normal
copy and one mutant copy?
That is, they are maintained
as heterozygous mice.
Okay, so rather than breeding these mice
and looking at the mice
that have no telomerase.
Now, we're breeding these mice
and looking, just like
in the human studies,
of always having the case
of having one normal copy
and one wild-type copy.
So that's what we call the
heterozygous generation one,
heterozygous generation two,
heterozygous generation three.
And what we saw was, remarkably,
there is progressive telomere shortening
as you breed these mice
that have just one copy
of telomerase instead of having
two copies of telomerase.
And so I'll just quickly
show you that data,
to make that point.
So if you have a signal intensity here,
and wild-type is shown in black
so you have this telomere
length distribution.
The knockout mouse have a shorter telomere
length distribution, as
we had previously shown.
But what was really important
is that the heterozygous
generation one mice,
shown in gray, are
shorter than the wild-type
and more importantly, the
heterozygous generation five mice
are shorter than the
heterozygous generation one,
showing that we actually have progressive
telomere shortening when
you have haploinsufficiency.
So this was quite remarkable.
And that gets back to the point again,
that telomerase is limiting in cells.
That having just half the level
over a number of generations
doesn't allow you
to be able to maintain telomere length.
If you now look at the
survival of those mice
and this is, once again,
one of those survival curves
that I showed you earlier
with the percent of mice alive
versus the number of days
and I'll just have you focus
on two of these curves.
The wild-type, so in black up here,
is the wild-type mice over 400 days.
And down here are the
heterozygous generation 10 mice.
Now, you see that there's
a significant death
of these mice due to the short telomeres.
And there's actually,
with each generation,
there's a progressive decline
in the viability of the mice.
And this looks very much
like the genetic anticipation
that's seen in the human families
that have dyskeratosis congenita.
So the inheritance of short
telomeres decreases survival.
And as I said, this resembles
the genetic anticipation seen
in dyskeratosis congenita.
So these telomerase deficient mice
have many of the same defects
that are seen in the human patients.
Bone marrow failure, intestinal atrophy,
immune senescence, they're
chemotherapy intolerant
and they show this genetic anticipation.
And the mortality in these mice
is due primarily to these
immune system defects.
And all of these experiments
would not be possible,
were it not for a really remarkable
mouse handler here, Margaret Strong,
who did all of the intricate
breedings for these mice.
So one of the most interesting
things about this set of experiments
was of course, every time you breed
two mice that are heterozygous,
have one copy that's
wild-type and one mutant,
you get out a heterozygous generation
and we can breed these
for many generations
but at each stage of breeding,
we get out, of course, the wild-type,
the next generation heterozygote,
and we get out the knockout.
And I can remember when Ling-Yang Hao
came into my office one day and he said,
I wonder what would happen
if we looked at the telomeres
of the wild-type mice that
come from these crosses.
And so he did that and
what I'll show you here,
is we designate that wild-type star
because it turns out that
with the progressive breeding
in the heterozygous state,
even the wild-type telomeres
that come out were
short because telomerase
is limiting and the telomere
lengths weren't restored.
So that's shown here.
Again, here's the
intensity of the telomeres,
the length of the telomeres.
Here's the wild-type telomere length,
the knock out just for reference.
The heterozygous generation
five I showed you earlier
is shorter than wild-type
but quite remarkably,
the wild-type five star,
that is the the littermates,
the brothers and sisters
from these heterozygous mice
also have telomeres that are significantly
shorter than their wild-type counterparts.
And that's because telomerase is limiting.
You don't have enough
telomerase to go around
and top up all of the telomeres
in just one generation.
So I've been making the point to you
that it's the short telomeres
that are causing these phenotypes.
When the telomeres get short,
you cause a damage
response and the cells die.
So quite remarkably, when
we looked in these mice,
these wild-type star mice
also had the same effects
as the mutant mice had.
And this, as I said, is quite remarkable.
So if we look at either
the testis apoptosis,
that is the the cell death
that occurs in the testes
or the immune system defects,
if we look at the spleen weight,
the wild-type star mice
had significant reductions.
So this was really quite remarkable
because now we have an
inherited genetic defect
but even now in the case where
the genetics is restored,
the telomere length hasn't been restored
and we still have an effect.
So we called this genetic disease
in the absence of the telomerase
mutation that caused the disease,
we called that an occult genetic effect,
a hidden genetic effect.
And it's because the telomeres themselves
haven't yet been restored to
their normal telomere length.
And now, this might be a kind of a cute
little trick that is, okay,
so we have something, we
now call it occult genetics,
but it actually matters because recall,
this is an inherited human genetic disease
and you have these
individuals walking around
that have heterozygous mutations
and the only way to treat a
number of these individuals,
for instance, who have
bone marrow failure,
is with a bone marrow transplant.
So you can imagine,
if you have telomerase
mutation in the family
and you have one brother that needs
a bone marrow transplant
because he has short telomeres,
that his brother or his cousin,
who may not have the
mutation in telomerase,
might still have short telomeres.
And so it's important to
know what the telomere
length is of the the donor bone marrow
rather than just the genetics.
So this actually matters
to the treatment of this human disease.
So it's the short telomeres,
not the absence of telomerase
that's causing the disease.
So just to round out this story,
it turns out that having identified
this genetic anticipation where you see
this worsening of
phenotype and earlier onset
of this bone marrow failure,
it turns out that there are other diseases
that these short telomeres are causing
besides the bone marrow failure.
And so the first one to be identified
was something called
idiopathic pulmonary fibrosis.
Idiopathic because we
didn't know what caused it
and it turns out that it's
caused by the short telomeres.
And this was recognized by Mary Armanios
because she saw this genetic anticipation
in this family that had
come into the clinic.
And so it was identified
that it was actually telomerase mutations
that underlie this other
human genetic disease.
And as we've been able
to understand more fully,
Mary has been able to characterize
what she calls a syndrome
of telomere shortening.
That is, there are a
number of different effects
of having these short telomeres.
There are these bone marrow
failure effects in the blood,
the lung effects, the pulmonary fibrosis,
liver disease, and as these studies
are continuing and ongoing, it's clear
that there are going to be a
number of different effects.
And very interestingly,
all of these diseases
are actually diseases that are associated
with the normal aging process.
That is, they are normal,
age-related degenerative disease.
So even in families
that haven't necessarily
inherited one of these mutations,
if you have short telomeres,
you may be at risk
for a number of these age-related
degenerative diseases,
due to the short telomeres.
So this is taken from another group
and this is just an example
of what I had shown you previously.
If you look at telomere length versus age
and this is now just
looking at white blood cells
from normal people, what you see
is that there is this decrease
in telomere length with age
but also what's really quite remarkable
is there's a huge amount of heterogeneity
within the human population.
If you look at a large
number of individual people,
you find that there's this great decrease
and there's been a
little bit of information
in the lay press about how, maybe,
telomeres can tell you how old you are.
However, due to this, of course,
hopefully you would know how old you are.
But (laughs) the telomeres
could determine, if you didn't
know how old someone was.
But if you look at the heterogeneity here
and I gave you a sample of DNA
and that DNA had telomeres that were 7kb.
Okay, that person could be 20
or that person could be 70.
So it's not something
that's so determinative
that we can say for sure
if you have a certain
telomere length that
there's a particular effect.
However, this heterogeneity
and this decrease in telomere
length in the population,
those individuals that have
the shortest telomeres,
we know are at risk for disease.
So you can model this
heterogeneity in the population
with confidence intervals
and this was done
by Peter Lansdorp and Mary Armanios
has also done that at Johns Hopkins.
And so what you get here is
this normal distribution.
So if you look at telomere
length versus age,
these lines here were developed
on 400 normal individuals
and you can say that if
you're above this line,
then that's the 99th
percentile of telomere length.
So this is the normal distribution
of telomere length in the population.
And if you look, now, in a
number of these families,
where you see this
inherited genetic disease,
those people in the families
that do not have the telomerase mutation
fall here around this 50th percentile.
However, those individuals
that do have the mutation
typically fall below the first percentile.
So those individuals with
the shortest telomeres
are the ones that are at risk
for the bone marrow failure,
the pulmonary fibrosis, and
the liver complications.
And as I hope that I've
been making apparent,
that since it's the short telomeres,
not the mutation itself
that causes the disease,
any individual that falls
below the first percentile
may be at risk for these disease,
not just those that are in these families
with these inherited syndromes.
So many diseases that are seen in families
with insufficient
telomerase share features
of these age-related degenerative disease.
So we know that bone marrow failure
is, in the normal population,
an age-related complication.
As is immune senescence,
chemotherapy intolerance.
Pulmonary fibrosis typically is diagnosed
in the sixth or seventh decade.
Liver disease and also, paradoxically,
there's increased cancer incidence.
So the short telomeres may play a role
in the wider population,
not simply in the subset
of people with inherited
mutations in telomerase.
So just to summarize,
I've told you that telomeres
are required for
chromosome end protection.
Telomerase is essential for
telomere length maintenance.
Telomere shortening leads
to either cell death
or cell senescence after
many cell divisions.
Short telomeres limit tissue renewal
and contribute to age-related
degenerative disease.
And then, just to come back to the point
about fundamental discoveries,
new discoveries often
come from unlikely places.
When we set out to understand
how it is that telomeres are maintained
on the ends of chromosomes,
due to replication,
we weren't looking to understand
age-related degenerative disease or cancer
but by following our curiosity,
it turns out that the
telomere clearly plays a role
in both these diseases.
So curiosity-driven research provides
unexpected discoveries
that can have important
implications for human health.
And these are the current
members of my laboratory.
We collaborate with Mary Armanios
and her group and many of the experiments
that I told you were done by past members.
And this is just a slightly older picture
of my laboratory when they
all dressed up as chromosomes.
(audience laughing)
And then the laboratory currently,
it's a little out of focus
but this was the political campaign
for the American Society of Cell Biology.
We are research giving a face
to basic science.
So I'll stop there.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)